كيف تفشل الدفاعات الجويه العمليه حيرت
الخبراء العسكريين كيف يمكن للمظليين
تفادي دفاعات جويه معقده متعدده الطبقات
والدخول الى القلب دعونا نشرح بعض المبادئ
البسيطه هذا ما يسمى بالمقطع العرضي
للرادارات الرادار لا يرى الطائره او
الاجسام الطائره كما نراها بالعين المجرده
وانما ما يقاس بمساحه العرضيه وهي بالمتر
المربع هذا على سبيل المثال قاذ ب 52
كبيره جدا لا تتسكع في الهواء وحدها وانما
تلحق بسرب من المقاتلات للتشويش وتحييد
الدفاعات الجويه يراها الرادار ب 100 متر
مربع وبالتالي يمكن للرادار تتبعها الوضع
مختلف في طائرات اف 16 هي تمتلك بصمه را
داريه تقدر بخ امتار مربعه وبالتالي
يمكنها الدخول الى ارض الخصم عمل مناورات
مع الدفاعات الجويه عمليات التش شويش لكن
الوضع مختلف بالنسبه لطائرات الشبح اف 35
على سبيل المثال 5 بالف من المتر المربع
هي البصمه الراداريه مثل كره الجولف مثل
النحله وبالتالي يصعب جدا
اكتشافها المظليون هنا يقدرون البصمه
الراداريه ب 5 متر مربعه مثل اف 16 ولكن
هذا ليس كل شيء الرادار عليه كذلك ان يقيس
السرعه دعونا نشاهد التالي
العمليات بدات ب 5000 صاروخ قذف في تلك
اللحظه بمعنى انه كان سريعا جدا الرادار
منظومه الدفاع الجوي ستتبع الهدف السريع
لكن كان هدف هناك هدف اخر في السماء بطيء
مثل الطير الرادارات حتى رادارات المدنيه
تقوم برصد كل التشويش لن تتتبع طيرا واحدا
وانما قد تعطي انذارا للسرب من الطيور
حفاظا على حركه الطيران المدني وبالتالي
ستقوم بعمليات معقده اخرى عدا عمليه الرسد
بالتالي كان هناك مقذوفات تسير بسرعه
كبيره جدا في ذلك الوقت 5000 مقذوف سريع
بينما هناك بصمه را داريه مختلفه صغيره
تسير بعمليه بطيئه مثل الطير بالتالي هنا
بدا الرادار بعمليه التفكير اي هذه
الاهداف سيتت ابع هناك مشكله اخرى دعونا
نشاهدها هؤلاء المظلي
يمكنهم الطيران
على مستوى منخفض اكثر من الطائره وبالتالي
الموجات الراداريه تسير بخط مستقيم مثل
الضوء وهنا يمكن
للمظليين الابنيه الى اخره لجعل تتبع
الرادار اصعب من الطائره وكل هذه العمليات
مجتمعه ربما تفسر كيف يمكن اختراق منفو
منظومه الدفاع الجوي